okay
hello everybody i'm um
i'm anka luca from xwiki and i would
like to talk to you
about um com
so i'm going to talk to you about xwiki
now um this
talk is called from zero to intranet in
the 20 minutes
the zero is that i don't even have
slides it's
going to be demo based if we can all
join hands
to summon the energy of the gods to make
this not fail
it would be amazing so
what i wanted to show you is um maybe
just a few words about myself i'm an
engineer
i think that's how you call my job and
today i'm solutions architect that's a
company that
does produces open source code and
provides services
um for this open source code
which is expected size
so what i wanted to do was to build a
cheap intranet out of an open source
platform
which is x-wiki and i wanted to imagine
that uh we have a company like a small
medium-sized
no small it would be small because it
would be around maybe 40 or 50 people
uh just enough to want to go out of a
word document
in terms of knowledge sharing and uh not
uh
not enough in order to not enough to go
to a
like a fully fledged solution with lots
of bells and whistles and really really
expensive
so what i want to to take as a use case
is the use case of a
group of people producing jam like a
gem to spread on bread in the morning
and i imagine that we'd have these
people that have the knowledge about
their job
and have all sorts of work that they
need to do together
and they need to not lose the knowledge
of what they are doing they want to
share stuff about their job
so i'm going to transform x-wiki in an
intranet
in 20 minutes go um
first we go on the x-wiki website we
click download
and then we can download here the x-wiki
version i'm not going to do it now it's
about 300 megabytes is going to be too
long
but i already have done that on my local
instance and i have
a virginix wiki here
this is what happens when you first
start xwiki
it takes a like has this loading stuff
but it's only the first time when it
started because it initializes
everything
and what we're gonna see is the
home page oh god uh sorry it's it went
in responsive mode because the screen is
so small
this is better this is can you see the
text you can see the text
okay so this is what xwiki looks like
out of the box it's an x-wiki and
it's a wiki engine so you can create
content
pages you can also create some
structured data which is the feature
that we will use in order to turn this
into a more uh job-oriented like an
expert oriented solution
so normally it's a wiki you have a home
page you can create uh
some pages i should probably log in it
could help
yeah admin admin
um so um
you can you can uh you have pages
you don't see the whole i'm gonna make
it smaller so that you see so basically
on a normal screen
you would see it a bit like this in
terms of like global layout
but i'm gonna make it bigger so that we
can actually read the text
um you can modify pages you have an
editor you can do text and then you can
do saving of the changes that you've
done
so far nothing surprising nothing uh
different from what you would be used to
when it comes to a wiki you can already
use it like this
for an internet because you you already
have a place to put
content a place to create users put them
in groups and give
give rights to the people for example if
you go to the administration
you can actually create a user already
there's already the admin and you can
create a user for example
the ros
berry okay
and we create a user now we have a new
user this guy can now log in and use the
wiki
himself as well so this already exists
you already have this in the platform
you don't need to do anything in order
to have that
so we can do content but we want to take
it further than this for example we want
to
be able to handle um
news we want to announce things to
people to make blog articles and things
like that so
we're going to go in the extensions area
of the wiki which is the interesting
part
and we're going to start installing
applications in order to add extra
features
to this platform so um
i'm gonna do a trick because normally
they come from the internet but here
internet is not the best place to go to
so i downloaded them locally
and i'm going to try to install them
from the local
folder so i have a blog application that
i can install ah
i'm gonna cut the internet of this
because it's resolving everything on the
internet and it should resolve it in
local
and now i have it
okay yes we should have
held hands under the rainbow in order to
make the demo work
because apparently
no it's not going to time out it's just
a bit longer
so now i have a blog application and if
i go to the home page or refresh the
page i will
see it here in the list of applications
so i have a blog i can
and i can create a blog article here for
example
apricots uh sorry in english is apricot
with a p
are here because we're creating gems so
it would be interesting for people to
know that
apricots are here i have lots of
features in this i can add an image in
my blog post
here upload
the screen is incredibly small i don't
see anything on it
i'm sorry for that so we have this
sent to the server okay we have an image
i can then select this image as being
the
the the display image of my blog post
it's a news
and i will also publish my blog post i'm
going quickly through this
uh you can go into the detail of the
applications just to show you that this
actually
um this um
[Music]
this actually works like this so you
have we have a blog we have the list of
all the blog posts here
and so on this job is done now we can
have somebody that publishes blog posts
for people to see
on this internet next step is we are
thinking about okay we have regular
pages we're going to create content what
we want to do is we want to put meeting
notes because in any
company any group of people that work
together we're going to have meetings
and we want to put the notes
so what i'm going to do is that i'm i
could actually use regular pages
for uh for the meeting notes but i can
also install an extension
in the same way i can install an
extension that would allow me to handle
better my meeting notes because
i will be able to have it in the list of
applications
i have the list of all my meetings here
so far there's none
and for example i can say that i want to
make a sales meeting
february
2020 and i have lots of
uh metadata like structured metadata
about these meetings normally
i would have like a regular text page
and i would just type text
i have a structured version of the of
the page this is a feature this is a
core feature of xwiki being able to have
structured stuff in your wiki besides
regular wiki pages
so i can i can use these applications to
make my data
more meaningful and to be able to uh
to handle it better as you can see all
the work is already done so i have these
beautiful forms
they have all the controls that i need i
don't need to work to do any of this
basically and it's free because it's uh
i almost said uh it's free because it's
open source it's free because it's free
and the open source is uh is another
thing so let's say that ross berry is
the leader of this meeting
and the meeting is in preparation
normally i would say here what we need
to talk about
and i can put the notes in here
okay i have my meeting and now i have a
list of all the meetings that are here
because the data is structured and this
is very important
because the data is structured i can
actually
yeah demo effect sorry for that
because the data is structured i can
actually
do this filtering this very precise
filtering of the metadata of the data
that i put in
if the data wasn't structured just text
i would never be able to filter by
status here for example to have a table
of all the data and and have them
filtered precisely by
a certain value of the metadata so
i forgot what else i wanted to show you
as i think i wanted to show you the task
manager
no not users extensions steel extensions
so
come on
so now i have also a task manager
and it also appears here in the list of
applications
so the test manager kind of is the same
as the meeting you have a structure you
have a table of all the
of all the all the tasks you when you
create a new task
for example create a social media
strategy
you can assign it to somebody you can
add a priority to it you can
actually it's high priority uh it's in
to do
you can have an assignee for it
and everything
so now i have the list of all my tasks
and uh
and uh and i can see them here i can
filter them because the data is
structured so
there's lots of things that are already
done like this that you can use and you
can install
there's an ideas application for people
to add ideas there's a bunch of
human resources applications such as
holiday requests application then the
recruitment application i also wanted to
show you that but
i'm a bit out of time now so i'm going
to go quickly so this basically allows
you for example the human resources
application allow you to
have some structuring of the of the work
that you do like not only send emails
between people oh i want to go to
holidays sure go to holidays
it's it it can work by email but you
want it to have a
to have it a little bit more structured
and what you would want also is to kind
of save money
and and not uh and not spend money on
one solution for each of the
of the needs of your of your small to
medium company
uh what's very interesting here is that
as soon as i create content in the wiki
it's automatically searchable because
that's how the wiki works
so for example if i look for social
media now
i will actually find the task that i
have just created so it's not separate
data it's
it's data like any other data in the
wiki and as soon as i put data
in there it is indexed by the solar
engine and i have this powerful thing
that allows me to search everything that
i have in terms of knowledge
um so far so good but it looks ugly
right
we want to give it like uh like uh like
a beautiful colors of
of uh of the peach workers of um
sorry jama workers so i'm going to go to
the color themes
i'm going to copy this default color
theme which is the one being used
and i will create a new one called
abriku because this is the name of my
company
can you still see the text it would be
so much more comfortable for me to see
the actual size of the screen
thank you very much and
basically i'm going to edit this color
team so it's really really easy
to make it your own like to customize it
and color it
to make it look exactly like you want
for example
i will use i think this is the logo that
i
built yesterday sorry that we paid the
company to build
i will change some colors to make it
more
white i will put my links i will make
them orange
for example more orange
more orange and i will also change the
color of the navigation bar up there
so the navigation bar we're gonna make
it white
i'm maybe going extremely quickly but
what i want to show you is that it is
possible to do this really quickly
uh not how exactly will you do it when
you will do it you'll probably spend a
little bit more time
finding the buttons but um
link color hover color no white is not
good because we won't be able to read it
still some orange i can actually copy
this orange it's so much easier
there and
this is also ugly we're gonna make it
white
sure okay let's go save and view
so far it's still looking as it looked
before because i didn't
set the wiki to use this color theme so
i'm going to go to the administration
and in the theme section i will choose
the abrico color theme
save and now my wiki is orange
like using the colors that i wanted to
use um
what i also want to do at this point is
okay i don't like these panels they
don't represent what i want to see i
don't care about these tips
i don't care about these things and my
home page is ugly so what i will do is
that i will also i will also go to the
administration
i can actually handle all this
these applications here i'm going to
remove some of them for example i don't
care about the help
i don't care about the sandbox i want
blog i want the dashboard at the end
blog meetings test manager dashboard
i save this and i can also
say that i want these panels to be
a small column and i will move
the navigation over here
and remove all this stuff
tip and i'll read the tips i want to
remove it
sorry to me come on come on
come on
yeah of course they're already there but
i want them to disappear from the right
panel okay
no worries it's at the end i'm not going
to spend too much time on that
what i wanted to show is that without
any coding whatsoever
what i managed to do is that
okay fixed it sorry quick really quick
so without any coding what i managed to
do is to give it a
a look and feel that corresponds to my
company to handle the applications that
i want to see here to make it a little
bit easier to work on
and now what we're going to do we're
going to work basically on the on the
home page
what i want to do about the home page is
i want to just remove
all this content and make it my own
what's interesting is that
i can actually include another page in
here and i'm going to include the
dashboard
so i'm going to make it display
i can use macros this is a feature of
the
of the of the wiki i can use
macros in order to say that i i want to
use i want to show in this page another
page
so right now i have a beautiful
dashboard with the pages of my wiki and
with the activity stream of my wiki
there's also notifications included in
this so i have a notifications panel
here i can configure email notifications
whenever there's a change on the wiki i
get notifications by email and so on
which is something that you may want
uh when you do an internet because you
want to know what's happening you want
to know uh
you want to know what what's what's
happening on your wiki and how it works
i'm going to show you now two features
that are
interesting features of the xwiki
platform that help you
make this intranet really your own
because we installed some applications
but there will never be an application
for example
or maybe there will not be an
application in order to define the
for example the jam recipes that we want
to use because
um we have some like some specific data
some specific knowledge about our job of
making jam
so what's interesting is with xwiki is
that you can create your own application
we saw the meeting application we saw
the task manager but we can also create
one that corresponds exactly to what i
want it to be
i go here i create an application
this feature is called app within
minutes i think this is exactly what is
left out of this presentation
minutes so let's try to make it in
minutes
so jam recipes i'm gonna call it the
recipes i think it's written like that
what i want here for example is i will
want a name
of the here i will want a name i'm going
to call this name
i will want an actual recipe itself
because we're not going to structure the
the data about the recipe it's still
going to be text but we want to add some
interesting metadata
for example what we want is we would
want to know
to we to which season this recipe
applies
so i'm adding here a property in my
application a metadata of type
list and i'm going to define here summer
i'm going to define spring
and i'm going to define autumn
and i'm going to remove these default
choices
is it on it's on i'm going to remove
some default choices
what i also want to do so right now this
is
done what i also want to do is for
example i want to say that one user of
my internet so one member of my company
is the expert of that recycle so what i
will do i will add the property of type
user
i will call it expert and
that's it it should do the job what i
will do also is to move the content to
the end
because this actually defines the order
that i'm gonna see in my form
i'm gonna move it here come on
at the end i can configure a bunch of
stuff in this application i'm not going
to do it now because it's long and i
only have minutes
um and for example i'm going to add in
my in my table of data on the home page
i'm going to add the season
and remove the location so this allows
me to configure that table
of of existing data that we saw i can
choose an icon for my stuff
is there any fruit here no but this is
the closest to nature that i have
let's go i have an application it took
me
[ __ ] the all the whole three minutes so
now i have my own application that i see
here
and for example i can add apricot
jam and the metadata that i have defined
is here
i'm going to call ross an expert he's an
expert in anything
here is going to be the story of their
site
you will understand what i'm why i'm
typing text
i'm saving i have my data here that is
displayed structured
and as i said before magically
everything is in
so if i look here for best apricot
jam
i will find my recipe that i have just
defined
so basically sorry alina i just saw that
so basically with
with a couple of extensions that i have
installed stuff that i have defined and
and still i didn't show you all the
stuff that exwiki can do
i have an internet i have a place for
the people that work together to put all
their data and to find it
really easily and also get spammed by
email when it gets
updated because that's what we all work
for spam
thank you
are there
yeah sorry uh sure go ahead uh can you
attach an approval workflow to um
uh actually there is an extension that
is called workflow that does this oh
sorry i need to repeat the question the
question was can i attach an approval
workflow
uh we the feature is not in the wiki
itself in the platform in the wiki
platform itself because wiki is about
everybody contributing
uh but yes there's an extension that is
called publication workflow if you're
interested
uh and it does exactly that it does
stuff that gets published
only when uh only when somebody signs
off
yes
yes so the question is whether it
supports integration and active
directory it was in the list of stuff in
the pitch
about what i will show you i didn't show
you but in the extensions so just as i
installed blog and task manager
you can actually install plugins that
will delegate the authentication of the
wiki
in uh like with a known protocol like
open id
ldap and things like that
which infrastructure do i need to foster
which infrastructure do i need to host
it on
uh it is java so you will need a
container for
for java it's called the application
server
for java i have seen it used mostly with
tomcat but i guess you can put any other
any other one a relational database i
have seen it used more mostly with mysql
but also with postgresql and also with
oracle because people do that
uh and microsoft sql i think i saw it
used with that
um and we usually put um
an http server like an apache or an
nginx in front of that
in front of that tomcat so you will need
this stack basically
and then in terms of machine i think it
needs to start at about
the cpu is more or less important
because there's not much processing what
you will care for
the most is the ram basically you will
need the ram and you will need
maybe a couple of gigabytes of disk
space and couple of maybe two gigabytes
of ram but you can also make it run on
less
depending on how many people you're
going to have on that and there is a
deadline
ah there's a debian packing gender
docker i forgot the name of the docker
stuff what is it called the docker
image docker image to test that yes
is there a way to install the extensions
in the installation process rather than
through the actual
wiki is there a way to install the
extensions within the installation
process
rather than through the wiki
no no there's no check boxes at the
install time but you can actually make
that happen it's not that hard
to make it uh actually the the ui that
we saw initially the blue ui that also
is not installed out of the box
when you first open you your wiki you
have a wizard i didn't show you that
wizard but you normally have it
you have a wizard that asks you what do
you want on your wiki so
if you want to make your own type of
packages that you would distribute you
can also do that and by default it will
install your packages which contain
also some extensions not the default one
and then you have to do it manually
any other question okay yes
is the purpose of the sandbox
application uh we deliver it by default
with a default ui
as i said this default ui is just what
the xwiki standard project has
chosen to deliver but you can make your
own uh default stuff
the purpose is for people to try out for
example the modification of pages and
the syntax
like how does it work what you can do
the macros i think without actually
touching any serious content it's a
playground yes
it's a it's a playground indeed
thank you very much
you